oh
[Musique]
si on est là c'est pour ça bon rappeler
le soldat vu un accident pour rappeler
l'accident switcher que vous êtes tombé
pas du tout salut serial est aujourd'hui
je vais vous emmener avec moi avec les
sapeurs que vous êtres paris on va
passer une garde complète avec eux on va
voir ce que c'est que leur quotidien et
on va voir aussi ce qui motive les
jeunes de mon âge à se lancer en tant
que sapeur-pompier donc les sapeurs
pompiers de paris
c'est une brigade assez particulière par
rapport aux autres congés parce qu'en
fait c'est des militaires ça y est
depuis très longtemps donc ça date
depuis l'empereur napoléon 1er en fait
il a fait mourir dans un incendie du
coup s'est dit ah ben je serai bien de
créer des mecs qui sortent des
situations avec du feu quoi donc y aura
deux puis s'est créée les sapeurs
pompiers de paris
essence d'offres
bon
non
or
voilà la recette
on a sous titré monial en fait c'est
on se dit tous bonjour comme ça on est
sûr d'avoir vu tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'on va faire le matin on
arrivait à faire que tout le matériel
sono chacun à l'eau douce qui permet de
jouer avec ok d'accord comme une espèce
de entre d'oxygène quoi servent à se
mettre là où pour la vérité tout le
vérifie karameh poste des indications
quand il ya du feu tout ça se met ça sur
le dos avec un masque en mauvais terme à
son histoire en masque aussi qu'on va
faire mais c'est vraiment un bel avion
tu montres que les épaules un stylo
france
c'est quoi ce que vous demandez si tu
peux me faire une démonstration sais pas
si c'est un masque en direct
[Musique]
de protection toujours la protection en
fait ici parce qu'ils se penchent
allegri pour voir les ok d'accord ok je
le sers jeu-là sport c'est même plus dur
d'équipé quelques films enfin on va
faire pas quand même un coup de coin
123e enfin à vos souris ça libère au
moins mal est fait la yaris est fait on
va les faire un footing
je sais pas comment ça se passait
peut-être parce que moi je suis sportif
la base mais ce qu'ils ont l'air des
sportifs particulière les gars ont fait
du tour de douche aux allures classiques
10 km heure 45 minutes une heure et une
heure c'est beaucoup on vient de
recevoir un appel dans le talkie walkie
donc je l'espère c'est quoi la com'
interventions mais on va on va partir la
direccte là on va voir ce que c'est sur
place
commencer un grave
non
l'ambassadeur
les surfaces
le temps
g lors du départ sont les repas sens
on grince paris
là
viens d'arriver
et ce avec quoi
ici
sur place
chan
bouger les pieds toujours
on est un peu choqué et trahi ce qui
s'est passé
et ben sont à chaque fois dans les
accidents ce qui arrive c'est les
cervicales
oui
merci
[Musique]
et
m
sud a vécu est consommé et qu'elle unis
big lots
il faut aussi savoir qu'ils
interviennent à toutes les 63 secondes
en moyenne
et il met environ sept minutes à arriver
sur les lieux
donc c'est du rapide c'est du direct
[Musique]
oh
moore
le centre de taez on attend plus de
renseignements et puis ce matin ils
n'arrivent pas respirer bon détention et
la concept qui les a sont déjà c'est que
le niveau l'altération de sa com ou de
l'oxygène clients pourront y a pas de
profil bas mais il a besoin qui nous
paraît qu'ils m'expliquent en fait
qu'est ce que ça lui fait exactement
j'ai lu ça vous brûle ou ça montrer
moins rock ne s'avoue plus mais voilà
c'est que cet endroit là c'était pas mal
ailleurs la vallée m'attend je touche
oui et ce où que nous la prestation
c'est le première fois que ça lui fait
mal mais ça fait drôle qui reçoivent qui
retrace le genre d'humour mais petite
ceinture français qui ont été comptés du
coup tu nous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé à une personne qui ait du mal à
respirer
et qui avait une
du taureau l'emmène à l'hôpital roi des
exploits là mon collègue il va vous
tenir debout on va vous installer sur
leur encore d'accord vous avez bien au
fond on l'a fait ici ça va mieux là ça a
été rapide sentais prêt
l'invention et je crois que comme ça
même s'ils sont très jeunes enfants
qu'ils ont
chambre
autrement
[Musique]
ce qui est en mon but lens tout le temps
il ne faisait même pas le temps de
manger
[Musique]
oh
donc il fait la zone ennemie ouais
j'aime la cuisine sans manger et le
salon avec moi relevé rich mesure de
fonctionner nouvelle donc ça doit
prouver c'est pas eu d'intervention est
aussi une travail joue beau
que l'alarmé je téléphone et les
environs du rhône on relooke tu vois je
me lève pas borloo travail dorsale et
soul
peux tu as une alarme qui sonne à bbb à
3 heures du matin tu te réveilles tu
descends par une rampe se montrent dans
un camion tu te lèves et tu es tu pars à
direct faut être passionné pour faire ça
c'est pour ça que tu vois je suis
admiratif ça les trucs comme ça ils sont
toujours au taquet toujours toujours
sous adrénaline parce qu'on sait jamais
sur quoi on va tomber
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on appelle du film en fait
que le baromètre de la forme la personne
quitte la planche le monde dans les
camions s'est montrée la franche et non
pas d'un camion
m
déchu
bakou
très physique c'est surtout une
technique là je pense que il ya deux
avec des entraînements il peut y arriver
voyez là
après faut que tu commets rencontrant
sur la mégane et on trouve un camion
[Musique]
oui
pour vulgariser la chose en fait on
non sur les chalets
les jeunes
ici tu fais 30 mètres haies
tout en haut de l'échelle on
pendant dix jours
on fait
peau neuve ça change
allez
tout va il monte à plus de 30 mètres
normale et aller ailleurs
c'était un projet
aucune soutiennent avec un jean qui est
crocheté là
il faut que ton pierre concernés selon
son chef d instruction et a marqué 15 kg
matériel sur le dos
du vertige et de la peur non ce que j'en
sois que le montage et la vérité avec
toi après non mais c'est ici des sapeurs
pompiers prennent seulement c'est est ce
que je serais moi en tant qu'entraîneur
c'est cette rampe et fort
sur les gros flou on peut rester
désormais
on respire dans les bouteilles
des milliards
en reste ont passé une demi-heure
en fait on peut aller change
à
et pour cinq ans et en fait le but c'est
d'être à ses comportements en laissant
ses bébés
impressionné par le poids
je pensais pas que c'était aussi l'autre
l une de mieux comme ça
à
je regarde arrive à la gare de l'est
donc à assistance à la personne
antécédents médicaux
je
oui dans la chute
en arrivant en gare de l'est
j'ai failli tomber dans les bras je
serai été prise de sueurs froides que
tous là j'avais les genoux frère et je
suis les casinos et les consignes pour
faire des examens complémentaires ce
qu'on a vu sur le but de ramé très qui
avait rien d'alarmant d'accord cluj à ça
peut vous rassurer en combat jusqu'à la
vérification puisque l'on conduit à
l'hôpital pour voir que déjà un voix
assurée pour être sûr tout est vraiment
rien d'accord parmi les premières
chansons comprend d'où afin de
transmettre à leurs coordinations
locales donc le chef-d'oeuvre
transmettre les premières informations
la coordination et suite à ça le médecin
on va nous dire justement l'a conduit à
thann percé on l'emmène à l'hôpital ou
s'il ya un smur qui va se passer
animations
[Rires]
[Musique]
elle s'entraîne deux fois par jour si ça
fait vraiment partie de leur quotidien
enfin le matin course à pied pour le
cardio des footings et le soir tout ça
enfin le soir musique il faut l'accord
de musculation donc j'espère sa partie
de leur vie ça permet d'être
toujours en cours
s'il ya besoin obsèques qui m'ont
beaucoup d'escalier tu portes des gens
des fois donc
tu as besoin d'être en forme à cette
époque mais c'est après jamel
je vais pas voter comme ça tu vois tes
j'ai peur que c'est que le moment je
lâche trop longtemps ma main où elles
doivent être les premiers dans la salle
bigotte
[Musique]
m
à
je suis dispo
[Applaudissements]
oh
les secours ou si j'avais pas fait de
vidéo je pense que je me serais pas
engagé
clairement ça donne un sens à ta vidéo
parce que tu tu aide les gens tu te sens
important du temps utile quand on
t'appelle tu
ah comme c'est comme si c'était un super
héros c'est un très beau métier et genre
d'engagement de haut fait parce qu'ils
sont toujours au taquet toujours à 100%
voilà avec les gens ils sont au top
sont gentils sont drôles
il s'adapte à toutes les situations donc
beaucoup d'admiration parce que c'est
des gens qui sont qui met de côté
tout ce qui est amis ni famille nieto
pour pour se consacrer aux autres en
fait et ça c'est où
[Musique]
combien de rire
distinction de première
marie aux mines
[Musique]
bah ouais
[Applaudissements]